welcome to this video playing my way
from Norway yep I have a long history of
of e 45 scottish games against images
want something else for variety reasons
so here we go got some Sicilian wow what
is this really queen bee three hand hmm
97 what is she doing Bishop c4 maybe not
sure this is this is helping helping him
ok so is attacking f7 I always have have
this Knight a5 idea so I don't really
know if this is leading to much so
Knight a5 or beef I'll be fibers also
after that he has to drop back a rabbit
it cannot be bad to just grab this
Bishop them yep take this and now like
b6 Bishop a six yes Bishop g5 yeah I
have to be very cautious I mean he
placed some weird stuff but it very
often has technical points so sometimes
just think okay this is complete
nonsense play some moves and then he has
a tactic like here p6 Bishop g5 and look
so let's see what I would be five be
five and then Bishop a six
d 5 is also not bad yeah let's do this I
have to play a move
d5 looks a bit strange because it it
puts a paw on this d 5 square Liam where
peace might come in but I want to
accelerate my development a little bit
here I am other moves I mean Bishop e7
es Bush of age 6 or something this at
least wins wins time alone but if he
takes our teague with the Queen and then
as I said I my development gets a little
bit accelerated if he moves the Queen
back like to eat to a half Bishop g7 for
Bishop b5
yeah i probably will castle him no yeah
of course this isn't a bad move at all
okay Bishop d7 I was thinking yeah
looking at b5 and thanks 94 I have a
queen before check that's no move what
is it doesn't lead to anything Bishop g7
I guess 94 there's Quincy six okay maybe
night yeah maybe you can do that 94
Quincy six queen before this this could
be an idea actually but 94 i can go
Quincy five actually Quincy seven
Queenie for is probably okay for me yeah
that is ok for me important research
them ok Knight e5 that's interesting
probably am gearing up form for Bishop
f4 so um maybe 95 95 controlling f1 he
goes Knight be five I can go Queen B 6
that should be ok
I didn't see that move which is a shame
96 taking on f7 am so I have to move the
Queen somewhere if i go to e7 maybe
seven nights e5 i can probably take on
e5 yeah I can Bishop g5 I tricky maybe I
have to go f six then I hope that is
actually working
gee I always have problems with his
somewhat unconventional technical style
not much choice him cannot move the
Queen not quite sure what he's doing now
95 maybe
maybe not see father I really don't see
what he's doing 97 27 should be just
fine so Queen seven
so what what is this here we remove the
Queen I can go rook c8 here maybe look
see 897 look-see for it should be fine
actually and okay I'm threatening
returning to take c5 and take g5 just to
clarify things if you move the bishop I
can go b6 yeah 497 rook c4 and it's
neither stripped tricky so be sexy all
right be 697 Roxy form and then winning
i think the night is trapped on 27 and
otherwise i just take the night with a
pawn who I was I was really tricky oops
the night is not trapped don't give me
that nonsense really so I go here
checking it with the rook night a six
and then
mmm he still keeps and protect I don't
believe it I might not 97 maybe this is
winning it I don't I don't see it I'm
f5f force also move and okay let's do
that f form trying to cut off the bishop
okay it still doesn't have many squares
for f4 no let's move thinking out of
this first
check who cage for is pretty strong now
white forfeits on time chair that was
weird f-word why was this night wrapped
it probably was yeah we always have
interesting games always okay let's see
I want to really get it get somehow all
of this so queen bee three funny move
okay here he six could have played
Bishop g5 that was interesting when he
went here yeah that's I was really close
to playing b6 and after Bishop g5 it's
kind of look I have to do this this year
and this is looking really weird maybe
it's not like terrible but why not what
you want so d5 is what I played chair
maybe maybe I shouldn't play it like
that that I cadet him Bishop g7 trying
to castle first 95 95 yeah computer
basically likes likes what I did takes
Queen takes here and rook c8 is winning
from black so yeah I played a decent
game then he has to go Bishop back
somewhere but then I'm definitely okay i
can go like v6 keeping him away here and
then castle next this is fine for black
at least its equal let's say I'm
blocking sorry I'm blocking his pawn and
I don't have any particular problem here
but this is winning rook c8 and b6 yeah
so this looks looks like a fine game the
only thing it was really I couldn't I
couldn't trap the bloody night of course
I mean the computer gives gives gives f5
so I played this right b3 look back ok
and still ok and now I just should just
take before yeah maybe I should I was
was kind of fascinated by trapping the
bishop but it still it gives a win so I
probably didn't do anything wrong given
given the time always like minus 2 and I
kinky 5 is a bit stronger now but it's a
win check yeah good yeah computer
totally approves of my moves that's not
happening that often and always can be
satisfied if it was a kind of tactical
game and the computer doesn't really
find a big blunder yeah that was a funny
game a funny game is wrong I mean in
very interesting game and quite
unconventional hope you liked it thanks
for watching